Speaker 1: So this week, we've been learning
just a little piecemeal about what was taking
place behind the scenes in the prior administration
at the start of the pandemic, one completely
off the wall.
Bullet point that we got was that Donald Trump
was looking at sending Americans who were
infected with the virus to the Guantanamo
Bay detention center in Cuba.
I mean, just completely out of this world,
bonkers insanity.
There is now a new report in Slate that summarizes
more of what we are increasingly learning.
And it is really wacky, wacky stuff.
The Slate article says the evidence of Trump's
pandemic sabotage keeps piling up.
A new book shows how he concealed the crisis
to protect his image.
And it is unbelievable.
The article talks about this, this book by
Yasmin Aboutaleb and Damian Paletta from The
Washington Post.
And it points out that they present their
findings in the new book Nightmare Scenario
Inside the Trump administration's response
to the Pandemic That Changed History.
The book relies in part on interviews with
former Trump officials won't be available
until June 29th.
But there are excerpts quoted in the Post
that describe several incriminating episodes.
In at least two cases, Trump tried to keep
infected Americans from setting foot in the
United States not to prevent the virus from
spreading, but to prevent the infections from
being counted as part of Trump's record.
In one instance, Trump's opposition to letting
14 Americans returned from a cruise ship,
the diamond princess.
The authors add backstage details.
Trump complained to Alex Azar, his secretary
of Health and Human Services, that the return
of the infected Americans doubles my numbers
overnight.
That was when Trump was telling us that 15
cases would soon be zero.
The authors report that Trump tried to fire
the official who approved the decision.
The book also reveals a second episode previously
unreported, in which Trump repeatedly proposed
that Americans who had been infected should
be shipped to the U.S. military base at Guantanamo
Bay, Cuba.
Don't we have an island we own?
Trump asked.
What about Guantanamo?
The word island was central to Trump's idea.
According to the authors, he was eager to
suppress the numbers on U.S. soil and figured
if you keep people off the mainland, they
don't count.
In both cases, the infected citizens could
have been quarantined at facilities in the
continental US.
That would have impeded the spread of the
virus.
But Trump, in his own words, viewed the presence
of such people on the mainland as a threat
to him.
Statistically, none of this should surprise
us.
Trump's biggest concern was testing, the authors
write, by producing test kits for the virus
and administering them to more and more Americans.
Doctors and the government were gradually
ascertaining the breadth of the crisis.
Trump chafed at this progress.
He said it made him look bad because he figured
if people weren't tested, infections wouldn't
be recorded and it wouldn't be counted against
him.
The authors report a phone call to Azar.
Testing is killing me.
I'm going to lose the election because of
testing.
What idiot had the federal government do testing.
This is not new information in the sense that
these things were previously reported, but
the degree to which Trump's sole and primary
focus was how he would look.
And, you know, the the unfortunate thing about
all this is that Trump doesn't care about
anybody.
He really doesn't Trump doesn't care about
his own followers.
Trump doesn't care about even people who support
him.
He cares about them as long as they're useful
to him politically.
And when they're not, he throws them in the
trash like garbage.
But the one aspect of this that could have
gone better would have been if Trump had realized
that the beginning.
The way to win this politically is by doing
what the doctors say and doing, you know,
look at how New Zealand dealt with the virus,
look at how Taiwan dealt with the virus.
Look at there's other examples.
It was really good for the leaders and had
Trump at the beginning thought, hey, forget
about the fact that he doesn't care about
people.
He never cared about people.
But if Trump had said at the beginning, the
best thing politically for me is to manage
this virus by doing a ton of testing, which
helps people identify if they're sick and
stay home and not spread the virus.
If he had done that, it would have been good
for him politically.
And as I've said many, many times before,
if Donald Trump had just done a passably OK
job on the virus, he would be president right
now instead of Joe Biden.
There's no question about that whatsoever.
But instead, Trump's concern was sabotaging
the spread of the virus containment aspect
in order to do what he believed, but wrongly
so.
That would look good.
And in the end, it didn't help.
It actually was a complete and total disaster.
Just a couple of other things here.
Trump and his aides belittled and resisted
life saving public health measures.
Obviously, the book reports that Mark Short,
a veteran Trump aide serving as Pence's chief
of staff, opposed the plan to send free masks
to every household on the grounds that it
would alarm the public.
Senior Trump officials ridiculed masks, likening
them to a training bra or underwear on your
face.
Short also oppose the economic shutdown that
slowed the spread of the virus in March and
April.
And on the rare occasions when Trump pushed
subordinates to move more quickly, he did
so for personal advantage, not public health
in the fall.
According to the book, he tried to oust FDA
Commissioner Steven Hahn for refusing to strong
arm FDA scientists into approving covid vaccines
before Election Day.
One anecdote reported in the book is more
significant than it might seem.
In late March of twenty twenty, Robert Cadillac,
a senior HHS official, went to Trump's senior
adviser and son in law, Jared Kushner, with
a plan to mass distribute masks.
When Kushner learned the masks wouldn't arrive
until June, he exploded.
We'll all be dead by June, he told Catholic
in the Post's retelling.
This conversation comes across as a tale of
delay and frustration, but it's worse than
that.
It shows how gravely Kushner and others in
the White House privately viewed the crisis,
which Trump was telling Americans publicly
the virus would soon disappear.
That is the epitome and a microcosm of the
entire handling of the virus.
We learned from the Bob Woodward interview
that Trump did.
Trump knew it was more serious than he was
letting on.
He said he didn't want to scare people.
Jared Kushner, based on this anecdote, clearly
knew privately how serious it was.
Everything that they did was based on their
worst instincts, their most self-centered
instincts, and a complete and total lack of
empathy and concern.
I mean, just a disgusting exposé.
No individual incident is particularly shocking
because what was going on publicly was bad
enough.
But I believe that we will continue to learn
more about this just about every week.
We're learning more about what was going on,
and it's as disgusting as you can imagine